it seems like every other week a new
video surfaces of police
killing kicking choking tasing or pepper
spraying an unarmed black person but
it's only because every other week
police actually kick kill
choke tays or pepper spray an unarmed
black person and
if you're wondering how we got here i
think i can explain it in a segment we
call
how did we get here
after every incident of police brutality
we have all these conversations about
racism
qualified immunity police funding
resisting arrest and
how ben crump gets on the scene so
quickly seriously
is he batman he might be batman but
we rarely examine how and why we got to
a point where
cops can literally hand out death
sentences to people
who haven't harmed a single soul but if
we're gonna talk about how we got here
we should begin by defining where here
is if we're talking about cops killing
unarmed black people then
here is on the side of the road with a
police officer's gun in your face
over a missing license plate here is
getting pepper sprayed
in your car over a temporary tag here is
a routine
traffic stop because since 2015 that's
where one
quarter of the killings of unarmed black
people have occurred
and another 15 occurred when police were
investigating misdemeanors or no crime
at all
see cops don't injure or kill black
people during traffic stops at higher
rates than whites
they just pull over black drivers more
often and
because they stop more black drivers
they just kill more black drivers
because
here's the thing no one ever says out
loud law enforcement officers kill
more unarmed black people because
policing in america is more about debt
collection than enforcing the law
according to the stanford open policing
project black drivers are more likely
than white drivers to be pulled over
twice as likely to be searched and three
times more likely to experience the use
of force
but here's the crazy part white people
are more likely to have something
illegal in their car
and when i say something illegal i don't
mean a bootleg
dave matthews cd i mean drugs now you
might be thinking
how do we know these traffic stops are
racially motivated because
according to a recent study at night
when it's harder for the cops to see you
they actually literally pull over less
black people
and that's why i'm moving to barrow
alaska where it's dark
24 hours a day how cold is it there
oh no never mind i'm not but just as
crazy as the rate at which police pull
over black drivers are the reasons they
give for doing it
take 20 year old dante wright for
instance who was killed during a traffic
stop this week
authorities claim police stopped him for
an expired tag and
when they ran his license they
discovered that he had
outstanding warrants the police officer
who shot him kim potter claims she
accidentally killed dante
when she grabbed her gun instead of her
taser because he was resisting
now most people think that cop storier
is shadier than woody allen at a girl
scout meeting but
maybe the more important question is
wait you had a gun out because he owed
money
so you stopped him because he hadn't
paid to renew his license tag
and then found out he had other
outstanding debts and
your solution was to make him pay more
money how does that make sense or
how about quran nazario he's a second
lieutenant in the u.s army medical corps
who was pepper sprayed by police
officers during a traffic stop in
virginia
and why was he stopped because the cops
couldn't see his license plate
it turns out that nazario's car was
brand new and he had a temporary tag
which
because of the coronavirus you can use
for an extended period
of time also i should add why the hell
are we still
talking about license plates if i learn
one more thing about license plates this
week i am going to qualify to run a dmv
oh what a cute little dmv lady but
that's the part of police brutality we
never talk about the part where
the people who are supposed to protect
and serve us have essentially become
armed debt collectors why are the police
acting as debt collectors
because in america we do this fun thing
called criminalizing
poverty and here's how it works a city
needs to make some money so
they attach a bunch of fines and fees to
petty [ __ ] that
aren't even really crimes like expired
registration chipped paint on your house
or
even in some towns wearing saggy pants
police are encouraged to enforce these
[ __ ] crimes and
of course they do so mostly in poor
black and brown communities
tickets get issued for small amounts 100
here 250
there but these are poor people they
can't pay
they can't pay they're issued a court
date that means more fees and fines
a warrant is put out for their arrest
now they're a criminal
you've taken someone whose only problem
was that they were too broke to keep up
with the tags on their car
and turn them into a whole ass fugitive
what an insane overreaction to a small
problem
that's like going on a mediocre first
date and at the end yelling
i want a divorce this country
literally makes it a crime to be poor
and to enforce that crime they give
officers guns why to defend themselves
if you think the police have a dangerous
job try being black
year in and year out unarmed black
people are killed
by police at higher rates then police
are killed in the line of duty
the police started out as slave patrols
but we aren't people's property anymore
we are and have always been human beings
with value the police are doing a bad
job because
it is their job to do bad the only
people who think they're doing a good
job are the people who benefit from the
bad
job they do it is a system that makes
money when we are arrested
and when they put us in jail and i am
begging you
system get a different income can you
imagine what kind of
returns this country would get if they
invested in
us so please stop killing us over inane
nonsense like license plates what's the
worst that would happen if you did
we all drive around willy-nilly with the
wrong stickers on our cars
what would we do with all those children
whose mothers and fathers weren't killed
because of broken
tail lights or suspended licenses i'm
sure we'd figure out something
maybe i'll ask batman this has been how
did we get here
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips
and a lot of digital exclusives and a
lot of this
you